it is 1500 GMT that's 6 p.m. in Gaza in
Israel where the war is now into its
fourth day the Israeli military is
bombarding Gaza Hamas is launching more
Rockets and the death toll on both sides
is rising within the past hour Hamas
fired a barrage of hundreds of rockets
towards Southern Israel it targeted the
port city of ashalon after earlier
warning people to leave ashalon Hamas
says it is in response to Israel's
continued pounding of Gaza with air and
artillery strikes at least 830
Palestinians have been killed including
140 children and seven journalists while
at least 900 Israelis have been killed
since Hamas Hamas launched its surprise
offensive on Saturday Israel has also
imposed a total Siege on Gaza cutting
off all supplies of food water and fuel
the World Health Organization is calling
for the creation of a humanitarian
Corridor to allow an urgent medical Aid
raso SAR
reports building after building block
after
block all are now
leveled many people inside including
children and the elderly did not have
time to
escape by midday on Tuesday Israel had
bombed nearly 2,000 locations in the
densely populated Gaza Strip and
promised to intensify its assault
leaving the 2.3 million Palestinians
living there with nowhere to
go the Israeli Army made a phone call to
a person who wasn't here he was in alal
we came running and they told one of our
neighbors that the building has to be
evacuated where should they go they said
they can go to the Sea people started
running and suddenly we heard an
explosion my brother's two children were
standing in the doorway they were
killed on one day the Israeli defense
minister announced a Complete Siege of
the Gaza stream cutting off supplies of
electricity fuel food and
water the unrelenting bombardment of
homes communication Towers hospitals
roads and mosques has become a daily
occurrence our area alal is a quiet area
but when I came here I didn't recognize
it it's completely destroyed all it's
features have changed this is unfair
this is Terrorism there's no Humanity
families here live in peace and do not
have any links to anything what happened
was Revenge a
crime people are searching for survivors
under the rubble nowhere is safe and
there is nowhere to go they
say we are told to evacuate the eastern
part of Kanan yunus and go to a safe
place but there is no safe place in the
Gaza
Strip This Hospital in Raa is underst
staffed and under equipped and the
number of people arriving here needing
treatment keeps growing some of these
children's parents have died many don't
know yet how much they have
lost now there's a real Massacre being
committed against innocent civilians in
the Sabra area there are dozens of
victims and ambulances and civilian
vehicles are still evacuating the
victims from this house that was
directly
targeted journalists reporting on the
front lines of this war have also become
targets they like many of gaza's faces
are now gone
forever the Israeli air strikes have
already killed hundreds of people and
injured
thousands but people in Gaza fear the
worst is still to come R SAR Al
jazer Jamila Abu Zuna is live inside
Gaza for us Jamila boats in the Gaza
Harbor were just targeted and we can see
the smoke Rising on the life shot that
I'm looking at do you have any
information on
that yes when we came back from the
ashifa hospital right here to arou hotel
that is right next to the uh uh to Gaza
Port we saw the Flames coming out of the
port after they targeted it target
targeted the uh Port uh with many uh
with many shots uh that were that were
targeted directly at the Port uh even
though there are many families uh uh
fled to the roots Hotel so uh people
were evacuating from different areas to
much safer areas but uh unfortunately no
place is safe anymore uh and after uh
the the um the couple of air strikes
that that were happening at the east of
Gaza were the mass were the m massacr
have happened in in neighborhood
inun and also
inan uh all of these places have
witnessed many Massac massacres people
have lost their family family members I
have seen people crying over uh their
family members uh trying to understand
the State of the State you're living
there are no words no much no matter how
much I try to explain or describe no
words to uh lever this message or this
scene that I have witnessed uh over how
much death and and uh unbelievable shots
that we have seen today you were
at hospital earlier what was the scene
there
yes there were multiple uh ambulances
coming from different areas of Gaza that
were targeted uh with tons of people
there are a lot of people uh including
children who were uh injured uh people
were running uh after their kids crying
over them one woman was crying that she
has lost her baby uh who was right uh
between her arms she was crying that I
have no idea where he where he was gone
he was right in my arms uh people were
people are actually losing their minds
over what's happening they can't make
sense of all these uh unprecedented
consequences as abuna uh giving us the
latest from inside Gaza thank you very
much